为什么别人用AI生成的视频
高级的像大片
而你的总有一股廉价塑料感
秘诀根本不在提示词
而是最近爆火的故事版
用故事版不仅能让你
彻底告别盲盒石抽卡
还能让画面精准度飙升十倍
今天直接教你最稳的
故事版实操指南
文末资料直接打包
记住正确的故事版
只需要装进三种核心信息
第一是分镜
听好了
分镜千万别放真人图
听我的
必须用极简的手绘版本
这是通过无数次的试错得出的经验
为什么
因为真人图细节多到爆炸
AI会误以为每一格都是新参考
而手绘只告诉AI一件事
镜头什么景别
人物站在什么位置
至于角色到底长成什么样
那是身份版的工作
别把压力给到故事版
想要身份版的高分提示词
直接看屏幕
建议截图保存
身份版加准备好的剧情
可以直接让AI生成一张多格故事版
它的作用不是生成最终成片
而是提前规划镜头
故事版提示词
也为你准备好了
直接拿去就用
第二种信息是运动
不仅要标出角色的位移
更得写明白镜头的轨迹
教你一招
直接在故事版上
用不同颜色做视觉化标记
比如用红色代表人物走位
蓝色代表镜头
推拉摇移
那些你用复杂语言
根本描述不清楚的画面调度
AI一秒钟就能彻底看懂
第三是提示词
这里的提示词
只起到辅助说明的作用
用来查漏补缺
精简描述每一个分镜里的
核心视觉内容千万别写太长
有了故事版和身份版之后
不要急着生成视频
下一步是生成一张预想效果图
预想效果图的作用
是统一整条视频的画面风格
提示词可以这样给
我们简单总结一下
单纯靠一张故事版
AI依然会翻车
真正能落地的高级打法
是必须祭出我们团队的核心铁三角
这个铁三角就是
故事版、定镜头、身份版、卡死角色细节
而风格效果图
来框死画面的整体基调
三者合一
AI才不可能放飞自我
人物身份版，剧情，故事版，预想效果图
都准备好之后
不要马上直接生成视频
这里还要多做一步
上传人物身份版，故事版，和输出样式参考图
再输入这段提示词
下面是这个分镜的剧情
它就会为你生成一段合适的对话情节
最后找到孟老师
上传人物身份版，故事版，效果图
再输入这段提示词
下面跟上对话情节提示词
即可生成视频
整个过程中 新手最容易踩进三个致命的大坑
第一个坑 故事版画得太满了
细节塞得像幅画
AI直接看花眼 根本抓不住重点
第二个坑 故事版和提示词打架
两边信息一旦冲突
AI就会瞬间当机 开始胡编乱造
记住 文字和画面一定要保持绝对的同步
第三个坑 别指望故事版能解决所有问题
它是导演 不是画师
角色长相 找身份版 场景风格 找效果图
各司其职 各尽其则
避开这三个坑 最后生成视频时
你的提示词反而要越简单越好
简单到什么程度
直接把画面核心主旨 一句话说清楚就够了
以前我们做AI视频 就像在喷运气
渲染出来才知道哪里崩了
现在有了故事版 生成前你就已经找通了全局
这才是降维打击
你学会了吗
资料也已打包好
N次方细节直接拿走